welcome back Hannity former deputy
assistant to the president dr. Sebastian
corker had an interesting message for DC
Republicans in a recent LA Times
interviewed now just take a look at the
title of the piece
Sebastian Gorka says the GOP did not win
last November Donald Trump did he joins
us now to explain what he meant he's
also the author of defeating jihad dr.
Sebastian burka certainly I would argue
the president and even today was on
message with the promises he made to me
the Republican Party has no identity
right now they're not fighting for
anything that they promised you agree
absolutely look the president won the
election the rank outsider the man who
was anti-establishment as far as the
ride is concerned and the left is
concerned he won on an agenda of make
America great again not make the
Republican Party great again and the sad
thing is Sean and this is the wake up
call and this is why he met with Schumer
and Pelosi last week the GOP doesn't
understand it isn't the Republican Party
that won last November the 8th it is a
New York real estate billionaire who won
and there's a reason for that
because they haven't served the nation
nation's interests for more than a
decade you know look let's be honest
here Pelosi and Schumer they hate him to
run their political opportunists and
come 2020 there will be nothing he did
that they're gonna like and they will
support the Democrat knowing the
president as well as I do
I suspect knowing Donald Trump that he's
basically sending of a loud message get
your act together or I'm gonna find
another way I still think there's time
and hope well probably the time is
getting short now you're absolutely
right this is the man who closes the
deal and he sent a very clear message
right the viewers need to understand I
saw a lot of stuff on social media that
the president has caved and he's giving
in to the Democrats the opposite is true
he will keep to his agenda that's the
message he sent me the day after I left
the White House he said I'm staying on
the agenda and I'd like you to help me
and I said I'm going to help you
he's not going to give up but if he has
to work with somebody else to get things
done he's going to do that Shawn because
he is results oriented and he doesn't
matter it doesn't care it doesn't care
whether he's got an hour behind your
name or a deed behind the name he wants
to make America great again is this
statement true that Republican inaction
and failure in lack of vision and lack
of urgency has pushed Donald Trump into
the arms of Democrats is that a true
statement
I think it misrepresents what he wishes
to do he hasn't he's hasn't pushed this
was his call they didn't invite
themselves to the Oval Office the
president of the United States invited
them and you know they say some people
said he was firing a shot across the bow
of the GOP wrong Donald J Trump fired a
torpedo into the hull of the GOP to say
guys wake Arika good I'm serious about
what I want to do oh I listen I think
his more important issue is serving the
American people he's got to fulfill his
promises whether they do or not dr.
korkor great insight always good to see
you my friend thanks thanks oh oh